today marks only 100 days left until
Captain Marvel comes out fans are
getting very excited to see her
introduced into the MCU and see just how
strong she actually is a lot of people
were shocked when they announced that
she's going to be the strongest hero in
the MCU when she's introduced how is
this possible how can she be stronger
than the Hulk how can she be stronger
than Thor that's what I'll be talking
about in this video also I'm still doing
my giveaway giving away a copy of
infinity war art of the movie art book
along with a copy of infinity war
Deadpool 2 or ant-man and the wasp on
blu-ray as well as some special edition
posters if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
keep in mind that this video is about
Captain Marvel being the strongest hero
in the MCU and not in the comics how do
we know that Captain Marvel will in fact
be the strongest hero entering the MCU
when she's introduced well Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige said so
himself here's what Kevin Feige had to
say in an interview with vulture
magazine all of the Marvel characters
have flossed to them all of them have a
deep humanity to them with Captain
Marvel she is as powerful a character as
we've ever put in a movie her powers are
off the charts and when she's introduced
she will be by far the strongest
character we've ever had so the big man
himself said that when she enters the
MCU she's going to be stronger than
everybody else we also recently got part
1 - the Captain Marvel Prelude in the
prelude we learned that Captain Marvel
is actually Nick Fury's backup plan
she's who he'll call if the Avengers
fail that alone right there says a lot
about her power if all the Avengers
combined cannot defeat an enemy then
he'll call Captain Marvel to do the job
that they all couldn't do together which
is why at the end of infinity war we see
him page Captain Marvel all the Avengers
have failed and now it's time to call
him the big guns so what makes Carol
Danvers aka Captain Marvel so powerful
well for starters she has the typical
superpowers that heroes usually have
superhuman strength speed endurance
intellect and she can fly not only on
earth but she can also fly through space
although she'll knee
a helmet of some sort to help her
breathe we actually saw this in the
Captain Marvel teaser trailer she can
also absorb energy which increases her
powers even more she can take that
energy and use it as a weapon firing
them out of her fists like laser beams
which we saw her do in the trailer as
well but her powers actually get a lot
more intense in an interview with brie
Larson who is the actress that will be
playing Captain Marvel in the movie we
found out that Captain Marvel is so
strong she can actually move planets and
so this has been an amazing challenge
he's so so strong she can move planets
so to me it was like how far can I go
with this strength lookout danos
apparently you're not the only one that
can do it
[Music]
in reality her ability to be able to
move a planet most likely comes from her
being in her binary form and her binary
form is really what sets her apart and
makes her the strongest hero in the
uncanny x-men Carol Danvers is working
with the x-men and is kidnapped by the
brood the brood end up experimenting on
her and augment her creep hours the
result of this was her turning binary in
her binary form her powers are taken to
a cosmic level when she's binary she has
access to the same type of powers that a
star has she can manipulate energy heat
light and even gravity her energy beams
can even become supernovae and be as
strong as a nuclear explosion
she becomes binary by absorbing massive
amounts of energy from a white hole or a
black hole so you can see that she can
clearly have the ability to move planets
while she's in her binary form now they
are changing her origin a little bit so
I don't know if there's going to be a
white hole or a black hole in Captain
Marvel or Avengers 4 but I do know of a
couple energy sources that could do the
job
one is an infinity stone since she can
absorb energy she might be able to
absorb the energy of an infinity stone
this would work out rather well for the
Avengers since they couldn't really
defeat Thanos even before he had all six
so if they could just get one Infinity
stone away from Thanos Captain Marvel
could stand a chance seeing as how she
could just absorb the energy of the five
other Infinity stones but we saw in the
Captain Marvel trailer she turns binary
in the movie and I'm not sure if there
going to be any Infinity stones in
Captain Marvel so another option for her
to grab energy from would be the quantum
realm an ant-man and Ant Man and the
wasp we learned that the quantum realm
contains massive energy and it's been
said that Captain Marvel directly
relates to the quantum realm somehow so
perhaps the quantum realm is how she
becomes binary and maybe she's the one
that leads our Avengers into the quantum
realm in Avengers 4 so that's captain
Marvel's binary form and that's why she
said to be the strongest character in
the MCU
let me know what you all think about
Captain Marvel's binary form and how
excited you are to see it in Captain
Marvel and do you think it's going to be
enough to take on Thanos and Avengers 4
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Captain Marvel and Avengers 4 thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]